depuis 30 ans plus de 6 millions
d'aspirantes infirmières ont été
soumises à l'examen du handc aux
États-Unis et dans certaines provinces
canadiennes il sera bientôt utilisé au
Québec alors si au niveau de ça surtout
là c'est ça qui orienté le choix de cet
examen l'Ordre des infirmières et
infirmiers du Québec a été blâmé pour la
qualité des questions dans son examen de
septembre 2022 le taux d'échec était
élevé et des changements étaient
réclamés
on a repris le prix un peu plus de temps
pour mettre en place cet examen là ça a
été fortement décrié par les
francophones du Nouveau-Brunswick
depuis jour 1 au Nouveau-Brunswick
problème de traduction manque de
documents préparatoires en français le
taux de réussite est moins élevé pour
les aspirantes infirmières francophones
en 2018 une poursuite a même été déposée
contre l'association des infirmières et
infirmiers du Nouveau-Brunswick les
droits linguistiques de la communauté
acadienne et francophone ont été violées
c'est flagrant qu'il y a des gens qui
ont pas pu faire leur entrée dans le
marché du travail ou qui ont rentré le
marché du travail en retard donc c'est
certain que c'est un effet sur le
système de santé ça a été la surprise la
Fédération des cégep mais aussi des
réserves face à la décision d'imposer le
enplex au Québec
développé aux États-Unis dans un autre
contexte puisse être je dirais aussi
rapidement que ça adapté et mise en
oeuvre au Québec sans créer un problème
l'Ordre des infirmières et infirmiers du
Québec affirment que des discussions
sont déjà entreprises pour assurer que
l'examen soit conforme au contexte
québécois
de personnes au Québec à former ça nous
donne un levier de discussion de
négociation avant d'entrer en vigueur le
enplex devra être appr ouvé par l'Office
des professions du Québec ici
Marie-Isabelle Rochon Radio-Canada
Montréal